اهلا بكم من جديد بعد امريكا وبريطانيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي النرويج تحضر استخدام
تيك توك على جميع موظفها الرسميين على ان
يتم حذفه من جميع الهواتف خلال الفتره
القليله المقبله وياتي قرار النرويج بعد
ايام قليله من اتخاذ الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبريطانيا والاتحاد الاوروبي
القرار ذاته فيما يخص حظر تيك توك حيث
بررت بريطانيا القرار بانه لحمايه
البيانات من التسرب
ومؤخرا فجر تقرير للامن السيبراني في
لشركه مقرها واكد ان اكثر من 20 موقعا
الكترونيا حكوميا نحتوى على شيفره تتبع
الويب التي اعدتها شركه
الام المالكه لتيك توك كما وجدت في مراجعه
لمواقع اكثر من 3500 شركه ومنظمه وكيانه
حكوميه امريكيه ان ما يسمى بكسلات التتبعا
من الشركات للام لتيك توك كانت موجوده في
30 موقعا الكترونيه رسميا عائدا للحكومه
الامريكيه
في 27 ولايه بما فيها ولايات حضرت التطبيق
وفق ما نقلته صحيفه
حاولت الشركه الصينيه التخفيف من اهميه
الامر واكدت متحدثه تيك توك ان تلك
البيانات التي تتلقاها من المعلنين تستخدم
كما في المنصات والتطبيقات الاخرى لتحسين
فاعليه خدمات الشركه الاعلانيه
في ظل المخاوف المستمره من تطبيق تيك توك
وامكانيه حظره بشكل تام انضمت النرويج الى
قائمه الدول التي حضرت استخدام التطبيق
على هواتف موظفها الرسميين لتلحق
بالولايات المتحده وبريطانيا في الخطوه
ذاتها
انكار مستمر من قبل الشركه حول المخاوف
المتداوله على الامن القومي الامريكي
فالرئيس التنفيذي للتيك توك اكد ان
التطبيق لم ولن يشارك بيانات مستخدمه
الامريكيين مع الحكومه الصينيه وينتظر ان
يدلي شوتشي تشو بشهادته امام لجنه الطاقه
والتجاره بمجلس النواب الامريكي
شركه
لاي كيان حكومي او تخضع لسيطرته وليست
عميله للصين او لاي دوله اخرى
مظله الدول التي تتوجس مما يمكن ان يفعله
تيك توك تتسع لتصل الى حظر المنصه بشكل
تام في الكثير من الدول
وفق الحكومات وشركات الامن السيبراني فان
تيك توك قادر على الوصول الى البيانات
وجهه الاتصال والموقع الجغرافي وشبكات
الانترنت وبطاقه السم ايضا والخوف الاكبر
هو تسليم تلك المعلومات الى الحكومه
الصينيه من قبل شركه بايت تانس المالكه
للتطبيق رغم ان تيك توك يؤكد على ان
البيانات مخزنه خارج الصين وبالتحديد في
سنغافوره وامريكا مؤكدا انه لن يستجيب لاي
طلب حكوميا صيني بالحصول على المعلومات في
حال تقديمه الا ان ذلك لم يهدئ من روع
المنتقدين خاصه ان مقر الشركه الام هو في
الصين وعمر العربيه
الامني الاستمراري وخلي الضيف من باريس
يتكلم اكثر نعم ولكن يعني حسب ما ارى يعني
مستواهم للامن البيانات او مع امنه
معلومات لا فرق بين هذه التطبيقات مهما
كانت من صيني ومن الدول الغربيه ومن
الولايات المتحده او من رويتش في الحقيقه
يعني هناك طرق مختلفه وطرق سهل بنسبه
للحكومه للسيطره او حمايه الامن نعم ولكن
يعني انا اريد ان اشير الى نقطه مهمه جدا
ان الحذر بتكتاك من الدول الغربيه مهما
كانت من الولايات المتحده او من دول
الغربيه الاخرى يدل على ان هناك يعني قلق
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده او نقول عدم
الثقه بالنفس وخاصه بالقيم الموجوده عندهم
مهما كانت مسمى بالديمقراطيه الغربيه او
مسمى بالحوريه يعني على بين قوسين في
الحقيقه قلق من تطور الصين يعني نعم
ليس من قلق امني لانه ساسال بضيفي بعد
قليل لانه كما تفضلت انه حتى وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الغربيه لديها نفس
امكانيه الوصول الى المعلومات المخزنه على
كل الهواتف وعدم الثقه بالتكنولوجيه من
الدول العربيه ايضا طيب هنا اسالك ضيفي
الخبير في الامن السيبراني
ما رايك فيما قاله ضيفي سيد الهام لي هنا
في الاستوديو انه الغرب لديه عدم ثقه
بالنفس يعني من وخوف من هذا التطور الصيني
المذهل ونجاح تيك توك المبهر وبالتالي
اختلق هذه الحجه حجه انه يستطيع الوصول
الى المعلومات المخزنه على هواتف الموظفين
الحكوميين اليس تقنيا من السهل على
الحكومات ان تضع تدابير امنيه لحمايه
تليفونات موظفيها الحكوميين الحساسين
المهمين
مساء الخير مساء النور لك للضيف الكريم
يعطيكم العافيه طيب لما نتحدث نحن عن
منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
كلها فيها يعني تتسبب بمخاوف
الخصوصيه ان كان للافراد العاديين او
للافراد اللي هن مميزين في الحكوميين
يعملون في دوائر دوائر حكوميه او او
عسكريه فهذا طبعا يفتح يفتح السؤال امام
الجميع لانه المنصات على اشكالها كلها
تتشابه وهنالك مشاكل ان كان سابقه ومع
دلائل واضحه جدا ان كان من المنصات من هنا
او من هناك فهذا هذا كله يسمح
اذا دكتور هنا السؤال اذا لماذا يعني اذا
كنا يعني مع الخصوصيه لماذا نسمح لوسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي الغربيه بان تخترق
خصوصيتنا وعندما ياتي الامر
لتيك توك الصيني لا هنا تصبح الخصوصيه
ممنوعه وخطر على الامن القومي
جميل جميل يعني هنالك هنالك حاجه كما يبدو
انه هنالك حاجه لاطر قانونيه لكيفيه
التعامل والتواصل ما بين الدول حول العالم
كل دوله لديها قوانينها ولديها خصوصيتها
وتتعامل مع هذه الملفات او الداتا بشكل
معين نحن بحاجه لاطر قانونيه عالميه تسمح
بالسيطره وتسمح بقولنه التعامل بهكذا يعني
ملفات او داتا وهذا الامر للاسف ليس موجود
حاليا وهو الذي يدفع يدفع الى تقسيم
الانترنت يعني كانه كل دوله لها ابليكيشن
معينه
وتتعامل مع اشخاص معينين الى اخره طبعا
الموضوع
نعم على موضوع وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
التابعه لدول اخرى ولكن سيد الهام هنا
اسالك
هل تعتقد ان الموضوع اثاره اللغط او
قضيه الامن المتعلق بتيك توك لدى الموظفين
الحكوميين في المؤسسات الغربيه
هو وجه من اوجه الحرب
التجاره التي بدات تجاريه واصبحت الان
تتخذ عده وصولا ربما الى التهديدات
العسكريه فيما يتعلق بتايوان هل تيك توك
هو جزء من هذه الحرب بين الصين وامريكا
بشكل اساسي نعم في الحقيقه اذا نتبين بين
التطبيق تيك توك وشركه الام
يعني شركه او تطبيق تيك توك هو على شبه
المستقل بالمجاره انا مع التيك توك
بالنسخه صينيه توين وايضا يعني هناك فصل
كامل
للشركات الام شركات
التي تمتلك بتكتوك في الولايات المتحده
وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك طرح من قبل شركه
التي تمتلك
وضع
المركز المعلومات في الولايات المتحده فكل
شيء متاحها للولايات المتحده او لدول
الغربيه لكن في الحقيقه يعني هناك الحركه
العولمه منذ عقود ولكن ايضا هناك حركه
مناهده العولمه او ضد العولمه من قبل
الدول الغربيه نظرا لان كل من صيني
واولايات المتحده هما المستفيدان الاكبر
لحركه العولمه ولكن الان مع دخول كثيره
وكثير من الدول في حركه العولمه يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده قد خسر بعض شيء في
العولمه لذلك يعني هناك الحركه ضد العولمه
لبعض الدول الغربيه نعم الدكتور امين هنا
اسالك على موضوع عولمه التقنيه وعولمه
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي سؤال هنا لماذا
نجح تيك توك واصبح يهدد عرش وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الامريكيه بالاساس نتحدث على
فيسبوك وانستجرام وتويتر بشكل اساسي بينما
لم تنجح وسائل تواصل اجتماعي اوروبيه مثلا
لم تهدد هذا العرش لم تكن في الصداره حتى
الروسيه منها مثلا ما عدا على ما اعتقد
تيليجرام بشكل او باخر ولكن مثل نجاح تيك
توك لا يوجد وسيله تواصل اجتماعي هددت
عرشه مؤسسات التكنولوجيا للتواصل
الاجتماعي الامريكيه لماذا نجح تيك توك
دكتور امين
يعني الوصول الى المعلنين او يعني من اجل
الترويج اكثر هل هي حقا منفصله عن الحكومه
الصينيه يعني بمعنى ان السلطات الصينيه
غير قادره في النهايه على التجسس عمليه او
الحصوص على المعلومات التي حصلت عليها تيك
توك هل هذا صحيح
يعني طبعا هذا ما يقوله يعني هذا ما تقوله
الشركه في العالم ويتوقع ان تقوم بتطبيقه
ولكن لكن في التفاصيل نحن ما فينا نعرف
ولكن تقنيا الامر يتم صحيح بالنسبه طيب
هذا عن المثال الصيني لكن بالنسبه للمثال
الامريكي مثلا هل الحكومه الامريكيه او
وسائل مؤسسات الامنيه الامريكيه قادره على
الحصول على معلومات من من فيسبوك ومن
غيرها من المؤسسات التواصل الاجتماعي
يعني شفنا سابقا في يعني مشاكل كثيره عند
جميع يعني مؤسسات التواصل الاجتماعي او او
يعني مثل الفيسبوك او غيرها وكان في فضائح
وصلت الى الى يعني الى العنان مثل انا او
غيره فهنالك نقاط ضعف عديده لدى هذه
الشركات متوفره طبعا ونحن نفقد او لا لا
يوجد
الاطار القانوني التي يسمح بمعالجه هذه
المشاكل الاطار القانوني المشترك التي
تتعاون عليه وبه الدول حول العالم لوصول
الى جواب واحد
لسؤال مثلا هل بامكان تيك توك العمل في
هذه الدوله او غيرها نعم طيب الهم لي سؤال
الاخير في المقابل هناك اتهامات ايضا
للصين ولتكتوك الصيني بانه يؤثر على
اطفالنا وعلى المراهقين هو ايضا يلعب نفس
الدور السيء الذي تتهم به وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي الامريكيه كيف ترد باختصار شديد
نعم هناك سيف ويعني ذو حدين ممكن نستخدمها
واي ضا ممكن يستخدمها لقتل ولكن يعني
بالنسبه الى تطبيق زي التيك توك زي فيسبوك
زي تويتر نستفيد منها وفي نفس الوقت لدينا
العزم للالتزام بقواعد نعم شكرا جزيلا لك
الهام للكاتب الصحفي الصيني ومن باريس
دكتور امين حاسبيني خبير الامن السيبراني
والمعلومات
شكرا لكم اعزائي على المتابعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]